a lovely day for a black man and a white
man to have a fight without being a
racial incident why can't you have a
fight because you just didn't like him
yeah
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people a brilliant guest we have for you
today is the former liverpool and
england legend john barnes welcome to
trigonometry thank you very much i
mentioned you're a liverpool legend so
anton is already triggered uh but it's
good to have you on the show first of
all they're no legends we're just normal
people normal footballers who contribute
to the success or the failures of your
football club and as much as fans may
see us differently depending on how well
you do as individuals as football
players which is what i learned at
watford and liverpool as we're all just
part of a team just like in here
to people of our generation you're one
of the iconic footballers of your your
era so you must be old
i am mate i absolutely am so but the
question i want to ask you is you know
how have you gone from uh that because
in your introduction i didn't mention
that you know one of the reasons we
wanted to talk to you is you've got a
book out the uncomfortable truth about
racism um
how have you gone from being a very
successful footballer then being a very
successful pundit commentary commenting
on football to where you are now which
is writing a book that's going to piss a
lot of people off on both sides of the
argument i haven't gone from being a
footballer to what i'm doing now this is
who i always was
what i was was a footballer who i am i'm
not changed at all i've always had
perceptions on things and thought about
things but unfortunately a lot of people
look at um
football and if you talk about
footballers themselves they get caught
up with what they are with who they are
and of course we're all different
because if you are a whatever job you do
that doesn't mean that's who you are
that's what you do so what i did was a
footballer but what i but who i was
always was someone who probably thought
differently to other people in terms of
discrimination sexism homophobia lots of
different things so i haven't changed at
all
so you always had this book in you as
what you're saying oh not necessarily i
didn't necessarily think i was going to
write a book but i always had these
thoughts and these perceptions and now
they've come out in book form so if i
didn't write a book i would still think
it so uh as i said uh why i decided to
write a book and why it took so long it
took eight years at least maybe 10
because i didn't go it wasn't ghost
written
i wrote it myself so of course i then
had to go to people who are a bit more
intelligent than me mean meaning my
daughter and my children and my sisters
so they could get the spellings and the
punctuations and the paragraphs right so
they're my words but of course now
they're all spelled correctly right
punctuations are in the right place yeah
and look before we get into some of the
the ideas and the themes in the book
just uh can you just give everybody
because i think when we talk about the
issue of race and racism now a lot of
young people in particular they don't
really know what people of your
generation in terms of football actually
went through playing in this country in
the 80s can you give people a sort of a
sense of what it was like
at the time
the book has got nothing to do with that
and um if i want to talk about it from
my perspective you go through different
things don't we so what did happen was
he got rachel abused from the stand and
bananas came on the field which other
football what can we say that's
different to that and you can see that
now so for me to say what i went through
isn't any different to what any black
player went through and with what black
players are going through now as much as
bananas may not be coming on the field
but if he's looking at it and it's like
on social media so it's all the same so
um
i the book isn't about what i went
through the book is my perception of it
and even number one the book being my
perception of it it's also my perception
of what i was going through it's
completely different to ian wright's
perception of what he went through just
to give you an example what i went
through was first of all you have to
look in the context of of of
where i came from i came from jamaica as
a 13 year old boy light-skinned
middle-class
elite family who growing up in jamaica
would um look at the discrimination
towards
black working-class people
from people like me light-skinned and
elite people and understand that here is
a similar thing it's not it may not be
it wasn't racial in jamaica but it was
still an elite in a non-elite situation
here it may be
racial discrimination but it's still the
same it's about the narrative that we
have been told about a different group
of people who we feel superior to or
inferior to so of course now coming to
another 13 years old um fully formed as
a human being fully confident in my own
ability in fact probably feeling
superior to most working class people if
you like um when white working class
football fans want to abuse me how can i
feel inferior to them so therefore it
never affected me at all i never
suffered racism i experienced i
experienced racist incidents but that
never affected me or made me feel less
than her unworthy or wanting not to play
football so obviously i completely
empathize with all the black footballers
who would have had a different
experience growing up to me who suffered
racism and it made them feel less than
and they feel felt unworthy because even
when i came to england we lived in goal
is green highgate and mayfair my dad was
a diplomat so we had diplomatic plates
and i could go to the higher echelons of
any any industry that i wanted to and as
a footballer i still can so what i
always felt as a 17 18 year old boy was
while i was getting racially abused uh
on the football field as much as i know
that if i came off the field though
saying people are abusing me to probably
want a picture on an autograph one day
probably individually um and when i
looked into the stand and while people
felt sorry for me or black players on
the pitch when i looked into the stand
and i saw black football fans working
class football fans who no one cares
about being racially abused being beaten
up no one speaks for them and we're
still doing the same thing now 40 years
30 years later 40 years later talking
about how terrible it is for the
footballers whereas nobody talks about
if you want to look at it from a
football perspective football fans who
get abused every day but no one talks
about them so let's go back down even
more so where this is where it affects
people in society and no one's talking
about what's happening the kids we read
knife crime
um education housing access to social
care and i said i've got a solution to
the problem in knife crime 100 i could
solve it tomorrow
let's start stabbing people it may fair
then it'll be gone because we'll do
something about it so that is really
what the book is about we have to do it
from the bottom up looking at how we
have to
have a perception of the average black
person it's also intersectional the
average woman the average gay gay person
rather than from the from the top down
looking to put these positions in people
in positions of power thinking that'll
filter down to affect everybody down
below so really that's the essence of
the book but of course as you rightly
say you can take little snippets of the
book and push back to either prove one
way or the other and a big problem i'm
having is because a lot of people on one
side of the argument are saying you're
saying nothing is racist then football
fans aren't racist any defending racism
and on the other hand you have people
saying you're saying everything is
racist so i just want them to argue that
between themselves i just do what i do
it's a very interesting point one of the
things i found really interesting in
your book was
how you were talking because you came
here as a 12 year old boy from jamaica
that
you were
judged more harshly even to black
players in the team who had grown up
because it was more like one of our own
was with you you were constantly having
to prove that you were proud to play for
england and play for the team well that
really came from a story that jimmy
grieves wrote about um the fact that i
wasn't born in england so therefore how
committed i'm into england and secondly
even more importantly then of course
growing up in in in the jamaica in the
70s even coming to england in the 70s
that's when the west and this cricket
team were the best in the world and of
course i used to have a bit of banter
with brian robinson and other players
about it ultimate westernize are better
than england and of course that was then
put in the paper to then show that i'm
not committed to england um so you know
that's understandable because this is
conditioning by the media to make us
feel certain things so if you want to
just use that as a microcustomers have
you been conditioned to think in terms
of
hierarchy racial gender or sexuality it
is completely understandable completely
understandable and i always use the
example of and it's not just the ones
who get caught who say something most of
us
believe that because we wouldn't throw a
banana on the pitch we're not racist
we'll never rape a woman so we're not
sexist and we'll never beat up someone
who's gay so we're not homophobic but we
are somewhere along the line all of us
it's not a binary choice it's not either
you aren't so the majority of us are but
of course because we then think that you
know we wouldn't do that we're not we're
not um racist or sexist or or homophobic
um
that that is the big problem martin
luther king said in 1963 that it's the
it's a shallow understanding by good
people
rather than the the total
misunderstanding by bad people is a
problem meaning it's not the idiots who
throwing bananas on the field who are
the problem
with systemic racism affecting people
here in the inner cities in terms of
jobs and education it's the ones who
don't think that they are and that is
why to use as a football example when a
female referee goes on onto the pitch
the vast majority of men think before
they see whether she's good or not come
in will go always say oh i'll wait to
see how good she is so therefore i don't
have a judgment but our initial thought
is i think a man will be better the vast
majority of us but we won't admit it
will we because we'll get sacked we'll
get cancelled and until we can have this
honest conversation like the truth and
reconciliation in rwanda and south
africa about how you really feel nothing
will change all we'll do is we just
cancel and stack the ones who get caught
and from the vast majority of us who may
feel the same but not say anything will
then convince society that we've given
the illusion that everything is okay
it's a really interesting thought john
because you mentioned being cancelled
and i think that's one of the
difficulties in having any conversation
i'm really appreciating the way you're
coming at it um because
how do we have a conversation because
we've got to a point where
any insensitive comment any insensitive
remark is automatically now
you know it's the worst thing you can do
in society saying something wrong and
you will get destroyed your career will
be ruined etc but how do we how like
you've just said something which i think
is probably true which is
a female
referee assistant referee a lot of men
will be like well let's see at le at the
very least they'll they'll have they'll
be extra wary right
how do we have that conversation because
you've just admitted that that's how
most men will think but if anyone said i
think a woman is probably less capable
you'd be you'd be wrecked that's what i
mean but so what we have to do we have
to challenge why you think that in the
first place so i think amanda will be
better and i'm happy to say that but
what i mean by that is that my initial
thought is yes aman will be better and
then before i even see whether he's
better or not she's better or not i say
to myself why did i think that
because i've only with myself and i say
why i thought that because life has
wrongly shown me that men are better
than women but that's wrong to think
that
so because i've owned it and i've said
then i can change it if i just go well
no i i don't mean that's what the truth
of conciliation is we have to be honest
with ourselves and it's not just with
women it's with racist with gender it's
with north and south i've gone to the
train yesterday i got off the train
yesterday at um houston i had to go from
kings cross to black friday where the
event was as i'm walking through there's
a lot of building work going on and
there was a conversation going on i
haven't got a clue what the conversation
was i just heard the man who i consider
to be the foreman because he seemed to
be in charge i just heard his voice
didn't hear anything else all i heard
him say was
that's a very northern attitude to have
now i didn't even have to think what
kind of an attitude that would have been
but i knew it would have been the
perception would have been an inferior
attitude
because that's how we've been
conditioned to think so don't blame the
individuals who get caught look at the
environment they've been brought up in
and challenge that rather than thinking
no this doesn't exist you know bias it's
not about in fact the book is not about
race i call it uncomfortably about
racism because racism is a hot topic at
the moment and hopefully get more books
out but to be honest with you it's about
it's about it's in very interest it's
about intersectionality it's about
because from a black perspective also
you look at what's going on in the
caribbean and africa and this is not a
this is not a judgment on the caribbean
and africa it's a judgment as the legacy
of colonialism which meant that from an
elite point of view you know because
there's still colonial um and from a
from an economic point of view um
there's still uh the legacy of
colonial exploitation from a financial
point of view because of course the west
still controls the economic so it's
economical colonization is still going
on so don't blame
black africans for disenfranchising
black africans or black or light-skinned
elite black jamaicans because this is
what has happened
but we're trying to simplify it by
making it a white and a black issue but
it's not because of course one of the
most uh discriminated against groups who
aren't considered at all in this debate
are wide working-class people because
they're they're they're suffering
equally as well not because they're
white but in other ways so this is
really what the book is about so that we
can have an honest conversation about
discrimination basically but do you not
think john that every time you know
somebody says something which is racist
or derogatory or even it can be a slip
of the tongue and you see people being
dragged for it on social media and you
see being it being cancelled and then it
turns into a twitter storm and there's a
pylon every time we have that it just
sets us back
absolutely it depends what it is that's
why i'm saying intense is the most
important thing yeah look at it for
example like with um amber rudden and
diane abbott when amber wrote said that
women have it hard in politics let's
have that conversation women in politics
have a hard time let's have that
conversation
a more hard-hitting and meaningful
conversation is that how hard black
women have in politics but amber wrote
said colored women have it even harder
is she not being positive about but she
said the wrong words she said cuddle
instead of black so instead of dan
abbott saying well you know you should
have said black not colored but let's
have this discussion about how hard it
is for black women she never said that
she said sucker because she said colored
so that conversation's lost you're so
right you know i used to run in comedy
club i've i've given this example people
who watch the show regular will know
and one of the acts was a friend of ours
he does an act called president of
bonjour he puts this military dictator
he's an african guy
and he does it and after the gig a
member of the audience came up to me
this is like a rural gig in tumbridge
wales a guy in his probably late 60s
came up to me and said oh i love that
first act you know the colored chap
because he'd forgot yeah and i thought
if if you'd taken that as a video and
you put it online this guy's life would
be destroyed but what was he trying to
say he was trying to say how good he was
how good he was adam hansen said the
same thing alan hansen said coloured
players are fantastic they brought so
much to the game they wanted to be
sacked i said to allen you know he
should have said can we swear yeah of
course you can go
i said you know what you should have
said you should have said black players
are [ __ ]
because it means you got the word right
black yeah and you would have been in
trouble would you
but instead of saying colored players
are good and you get in trouble for that
but he's trying to praise us and say how
good we are greg clark went through the
same thing when he talked about colored
people but then he went on to say also
and this is where the nuances around um
language and understanding particularly
with with new concepts coming forward
every day and greg clark said about
gay uh he would love a gay player to
come out he gets so much support you get
so much love and trust and this is what
we need to support the gay community
because we'd love a gay player to come
out because you know he made a live
choice to be gay oh no he didn't
obviously but of course he doesn't know
it but he's trying to be positive with
saying what's gay people to come out and
because of his age he doesn't understand
that he's now been cancelled and now
he's left his job because of that and i
say to young people now who use language
particularly just language as as the
marker rather than intent in 30 years
time whatever you're using now may
change oh yeah and then five years
yeah five years time ten years time then
what's gonna happen when you are used to
saying something and you have the right
intention but you say the wrong thing do
you expect them to be sacked or
cancelled so that is why intent is the
is the most important thing for me
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
ridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anthem has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
it it's amazing how we tinker with
language but we're more obsessed about
discussing whether being is racist then
actually having the discussion because
it's easy well it's very similar to
taking the knee the discussion is now
not about why we're taking the knee and
and a tangible difference that's made
because we're highlighting a problem
it's not whether we have the right to
take the knee if you look at the metoo
movement which was started by tarana
burke many years ago to highlight the um
sexual abuse for young black girls in
the inner cities that's not me too
movement is meeting movements about a
hollywood actress who was abused by
harvey weinstein and elite groups of
women who now may be you know not being
given opportunities because of sexism
whereas that's not what it was that's
not what it was so it's been hijacked by
an elite group of people for their own
end rather than the original meaning so
just like taking the nearby colin
kaepernick was about injustice and
police in the inner cities it's now
about i have the right to take the knee
so the discussion now isn't about why
we're taking the knee is should we take
any or not what for don't really care
but we should still do it because as
we've passed the red card down the line
in the champions league for
25 years
that's made no difference what it does
is it highlights the problem so what
football can do is highlight the problem
you can't change or solve the problem
but we believe just by highlighting it
that's enough and the more we just keep
talking about that and feeling that
we're doing something we're doing
something doing something nothing
changes for the majority of people do
you support the wilford zaha position i
don't know if you know his position
which is i'm not going to take the knee
because it's a token gesture and
therefore
i support his decision and i support the
decision of the people who want to take
the knee just to highlight the problem
because wilfred zaha not taking the knee
doesn't solve the problem either what it
does it highlights it highlights his
stance and are making a stance against
it but just by not taking the maybe even
doing that that's not going to change
anything either what's going to change
something is just to have it make a
tangible difference is to talk about why
are we taking in the first place what am
i standing and doing there that's why i
use marcus rashford as an example marcus
rashford who single-handedly changed
government policy towards and this is
nothing to do with race but it's to do
with underprivileged he used his his
platform to change government policy
about feeding underprivileged kids with
free school dinners
not about
eastern european races fans or stream
bananas on the field to stop doing that
because eastern european fans rang up
and on the field of racially abusing of
course it's wrong and we have to do
something about that but that is not the
reason why there are kids stabbing each
other in london and and can't get jobs
and housing and a good education and the
more we just focus on that and ignore
that and think that that's making a
difference what's that's making a
difference to are
footballers nobody else
so yes we have to do both as people keep
telling me but we're not doing both the
elites are talking about things that are
going to affect them and
systemic racism doesn't affect
footballers individual acts of racism
bananas on the field and for the other
six days of the week
the system rewards them and the money
they make the houses they live the
places they can go they can go to all
the elite places which the system allows
them to
systemic racism affects people in the
black in in the community and that is
where we have to really tackle it yes we
have to do both but we're not doing both
john one of the things that i'm a bit
confused then to to clear up is i think
what you're saying quite a lot and you
mentioned this a lot obviously in the
book is it's a largely a class issue
right
so well not just class elitism as well
yeah it's quite nuanced but yeah go
ahead what's the difference between
class and elitism because it can have
not because you can have um
working-class people who are elite
footballers are working class the
majority of them but they are in an
elite system because they're allowed to
be there
i mean
footballers are obviously a tiny
minority of society exactly actors
singers rappers yeah but these are the
ones who are we are focusing on they're
tiny
tiny they're a tiny group of
disenfranchised people but we're we're
disproportionately making out that
they're the what we have to do is we
have to support them more than more than
the masses yeah i guess what i'm getting
at and i'm just posing this as a devil's
advocate understand this
is it helpful to add race into the
conversation or is it just a class issue
in terms of focusing on solving it
absolutely not of course you have to
have race into it when race is
applicable right but there are times
when race isn't applicable but of course
because everything isn't racist and
that's the point i'm trying to make i
guess what i'm saying let me give you an
example so take education for example
right people talk about problems for uh
uh people from the uh afro-caribbean
community particularly specifically in
education and what you see is west
africans for example do very well in
this country support the caribbean boys
exactly yeah and white boys do you even
work with us white working class boys
even worse and even indian boys to
bangladeshi boys exactly of course so so
i would argue that's not i mean it might
be an element of race involved but if
you look at it on on the surface you're
going well white boys are at the bottom
of the pile yeah africans and
indians are doing great that's not a
race issue that's a class issue it's not
a class because bangladeshi boys aren't
necessarily a lower class or black west
african boys on a lower class the
caribbean boys so that's not class so
what is this that could be cultural
because culturally i'm not allowed to
say that you are well yeah but well it
could be that's what i'm saying and it
could because if you look at indians to
pakistanis for example because of course
you know the caste system in india has
nothing to do with you know whether
you're indian or bangladesh or pakistani
right so that those are the nuances
around you and these are the
conversations so glad you said but
unfortunately what has been what has
been pushed into it and that's why it's
quite good to be black now because we
can say a lot of things and get away
with it that's one of the good things
about being black because i know white
people can't and of course you know
yeah
you've recently become white because
greeks weren't necessarily wise
they're taking little bits out of the
book and they've had this conversation
go oh that's terrible because the whole
idea of are the are they due to a race
of people in terms of because you can
have blind hair blue-eyed jews you can
have ashkenazi jews you can have
cephalic jews you can have black jews
yeah so if you have ethiopian jews are
they are they negroes of black or what
are they and it's more to do with the
fellow everybody's discriminated against
but you can't just lump everything with
race yeah and what is race and what is
racism there are certain discriminations
that aren't racism i would love the day
to go back not to go back to the old
days but i love a day i love a day for a
black man and a white man to have a
fight without being a racial incident
why can't you have a fight because you
just didn't like him yeah
music to our ears man it's true but we
seem to live in this society where
everything is becoming hyper racialized
yet we don't want to solve the problems
that we have
we would prefer to win an argument than
to solve a problem and when we've
reached that point you think well we're
screwed up well because we're just
because we are arguing at this lower
level which is completely
inconsequential to the real
problem which is up here whereby it's
about discrimination for different
groups of people and the more people
discriminate again against the better
the system works we live in a capitalist
society this is what happens cap this is
what capitalism is the more people we
can disenfranchise and exploit for the
few but what will happen now because we
are now becoming more enlightened you
have to then allow more people
to become the few so lots of black
people become the few a few women become
the few and it's still discriminated
against the masses so the point i'm
making is that once we get rid of
discrimination racial discrimination
homophobia and sexism to name just a few
their other dynamics the vast majority
of black people women and gay people
will still be exactly where they are
but it won't be because they're women
black or gay it'll be all the dynamics
then it'll be the way the world should
be the people are willing to get up and
work hard the people are willing to go
to school the people are willing to
study they will be rewarded because at
this moment in time as much as we say
that that is applicable to everybody
it's not because there's certain black
people
bangladeshis other people who these
opportunities aren't afforded to because
of the negative perception we have of
them no matter how hard they work and
you will still have many black people
bangladeshis women who will get to the
top despite not being given an
opportunity because they're not they're
because of their innate human qualities
and then they're used as an
example that see you can do it as well
because they did it
what we have to do is provide an
environment for everybody to do it
fairly and still the ones who are
willing to work hard will then get there
rather than the majority of people are
up there disproportionately are
white middle-class men and because
you're white middle-class men a lot of
them not all of them of course
the majority of them deserve to be there
but because we have a perception of that
particular group it is disproportionate
and productivity will go because you'll
have the right people for the right job
see this is where you start
will be
working in the inner cities working jobs
and not being given opportunities but
the opportunities that they won't get
won't be because that they're black or
because they're women it'll be because
they're not prepared to work hard
they're not clever enough they're not
intelligent enough that's why the whole
idea of of of of you know um
this this idea that everything has to be
equal from a political point of view um
that's why socialism never worked
socialism can't work in the modern age
because of course there are people who
won't always want to work harder than
somebody else to be rewarded more but if
you're going to say that you're not
going to be rewarding more because
everyone's going to be the same what's
the point of working harder so we're not
going to be as productive i'm from the
soviet union you don't need to tell me
exactly yeah
flip it out you're jewish russian greek
you're flipping everything on you got
into jamaican india yeah
yes so that's why it doesn't work and
you can see yeah obviously russia and
china now they've got millionaires and
stuff like that so i'm not saying that
we want everything to be equal but at
this moment in time what we're trying to
sell particularly black people is that
the reason why you're not there is
because it's racism now lots of black
people aren't there because they're lazy
like white people are lazy and
everybody's lazy but that's not what
we're saying that's not what we're
saying we're saying it's because of this
so i did a thought the other day hold on
hold on
you're you're saying a lot of very
interesting things and i think i i just
want to take one at a time so
you
i'm not going to repeat what you said
because i'll get you you'll get in
trouble yeah a lot of black people are
lazy
if you take that in isolation then of
course
i know exactly what you mean
but there you go now this is going out
unedited that's the point of the show
right so you're not going to get
misrepresented out of this well not by
us anyway yeah
but what i'm saying is so you're saying
basically racism isn't what's stopping
those people from achieving quite often
racism is what's stopping some people
the people who are enamored with those
qualities to be willing to get to go to
work study hard but the system
discriminates against them and women and
other groups of people
they're going to be the odd one of those
who despite all of that will still make
it but there are lots of them who won't
make it because the system is designed
to stop them making it
how is the system designed to stop them
john
because we live in a capitalist world
and capitalism is about the the control
of production by a few people and
everybody else does the work and some
people benefit
a minority benefits right so if you go
back to to from a political point of
view china should have been the first
capitalist
china it's in the book i don't know if
you've got to that point yet because
before christopher columbus discovered
america there was a maritime leader in
china called zhang he who china had
biggest ships that even have now and
they had more they were stronger
militarily um from a scientific point of
view they were ahead of everybody else
and they were going to they were trading
in india these are merchants trading in
india trading in east africa this is
before christopher columbus even went
and what the government did they
recognized that if we allow this to
continue those merchants
will become disproportionately richer
than the population and then they will
be able to influence the politics which
would mean that they would become even
more richer because they'd be in
influence politics and policy to the
detriment of the average person so they
burnt every one of those ships to stop
that because they knew but what did we
do in europe we did the opposite so the
merchants became powerful so it became
disproportionate the wealth and the
equality became disproportionate and
that's what we have to this day
now we can't go back so it's not a
question of going back to socialism or
common because it doesn't work as you
can see in china and india but just to
give you an example of how capitalism is
about
disproportionately discriminating and
exploiting the masses for the few and
that's and that's and that's the world
we live in and we know where we want to
be all of us yeah but we're willing to
work hard to do so right so this is the
point which is why i you use the word
utopia but i can't come back to this
because you know we've had a lot of
behind you there's brett weinstein one
of the world's most prominent
evolutionary biologists we've had a
bunch of them on the show
are we ever going to live in a society
where i mean we evolved to to live in
hierarchies right that's what we evolved
to be yeah so are we ever going to get
to a point when there aren't a lot of
people a small number of people at the
top who control
most of what happened i doubt it not in
our lifetime because there are people
who are always going to be willing to
work harder than others and therefore
they should be rewarded but at this
moment in time it is unrealistic in
terms of the the people we think
are more deserving because of what we've
been conditioned to think and going back
for 300 years once we were then told
that to legitimize slavery and
colonialism particularly forget slavery
colonialism that these group of people
are inferior to us so therefore there's
some people who we have now been
conditioned to think are inferior to us
there's a nice group we can then
discriminate against without it
necessarily
bothering everyone else because
we know that they're inferior and we
know women are inferior we wrongly know
that so therefore if you condition our
minds whereby
the reality of who is inferior and who
is not is just about your own individual
quality then you'll see lots of black
people lots of women lots of gay people
lots of northerners being in these
positions because they're willing to
work hard and you'll still have the same
amount of people being discriminated
against but then it'll be more it'll be
fairer in terms of
the people we discriminate against and
i'm not saying they deserve to be
discriminated against because you have
to look at different issues regarding
geography and where you're born and when
you're born as to who is going to be
this group because if the greeks had
lost that war all those years ago
against the the the persians you know
europeans would have been the ones who
would be the black people if you like
so um
and it's quite a complex
way of looking at it but that is what we
have to do because the way that we were
convinced in terms of racial hierarchy
and sexual hierarchy was a very complex
way it's not stupid people elenius bloom
and back the most intelligent minds sold
us this lie about
characteristics mental characteristics
moral characteristics of different
groups of people which was a lie which
have now been debunked so even the idea
of race doesn't exist there's no there's
no race you let's go past the statement
55 that race biologically and
genetically doesn't exist unfortunately
we're too far now to start that
conversation because it's become a
reality in our own mind but what we have
to do is now change the perception of
the
intellectual and moral characteristics
that were put on the races
so
that being the case
number one how do you do that and number
two do you agree with quotas do you
agree with that kind of system no we
deconstruct what we've learned that's
how we do that we deconstruct what we've
done so why why do we feel that white
people are superior no we don't yes we
do because of what every single day what
does the media say every single day what
does the media say about
jamaican yards nigerian drug dealers um
nigerian con men muslim terrorists so
that gives us a negative perception of
terrorists drug dealers and groomers but
also muslims nigerians and jamaicans
this is how we have become conditioned
i pushed back against that john because
after brexit we were conditioned to
think the white working class was stupid
racist and whatever else for voting not
after brexit they always thought yeah
yeah
they always got that
that's true not only did they always
think that yeah what they did after
brexit is they then said like they said
to the white working class is the reason
for your discontent mr white working
class man is because these foreigners
are coming here and they're taking your
benefits and they're taking your council
houses your shitty benefits at city
council houses and working-class people
went yeah we don't want to come over
instead of thinking we don't want more
we don't want them we want more for
ourselves so the reason for our
discontent is them so we hate you then
we're saying to the to the to the black
people and other people the reason for
your discontent is those white
working-class football fans and eastern
european fans of course they just put us
against each other
like for example women and black people
black lives matter so what do we have on
in the newspaper um 10 years for
throwing a statue in the river but two
years for rape
what a woman supposed to think then what
are the media trying to do women are
going to go black lives matter flipping
they're always getting everything they
want and it's only two years for rape
they're putting us against each other
and they've always done that divide and
conquer that's why the groups should be
together are disenfranchised groups and
even when you talk about the the you
speak to football fans and you say to
them you know why are you against taking
the knee
marxism
marxism
i don't know if they know much about
marxism i'm not saying they're stupid
but i don't know enough about marxism to
know that but of course
i do i don't know if they know that
white working-class people should be
marxist marxism is about protecting them
and they're right and giving them more
equality
um
defending the police yeah
i'm talking about the essence of what it
was of course it can be but everything
can be changed everything can be changed
look at the labor party on the is now
changing
yes it was so so i'm talking about the
essence of it
so
defunding the police
marxism about defending police marx is
about getting rid of poverty if you get
rid of a poverty there's less crime less
crime you don't need as much police and
the funds can be used for something else
to help working-class people but of
course once you just talk about it's
about these funding buddies which it
isn't so it's quite nuanced and if
people don't understand that they just
go along with what with what they hear
so um
i suppose that is where you look at it
from an elite and a non-elite point of
view i think the elite point of view is
interesting i mean i take issue with the
marxism stuff because
um
first of all there's a reason i said it
used to be i mean it never worked in the
first place but it could never work
because a man's individual greed so i
understand that i'm talking about the
the the philosophy behind it you make
the point in the book about greed i
don't know i agree with that either i
think well as i say i think we evolved
to live in hierarchy and it's the nature
especially for males uh but but for
everybody to seek status in society and
to seek to advance their own law
and so we'll always be uh we'll all
we'll always be striving when you were
on the football field you wanted to win
yeah right and everybody wants to win at
life everybody wants to move up in the
world and that's why that's why
socialism doesn't depends what you mean
i agree with you but it depends what you
mean by evolution evolution is very
natural the idea of wanting more is not
natural
that is not naturally in us because if
it was naturally in us do you want more
than yours than your son or your
children would you have more would you
want more food than your children they
have my genes and the point of my life
is to pass my genes on to them so that
they can pass their genes on so usually
my children are almost different
than you yes yes of course but if it was
natural for us to want more than
everybody else you would want more than
your children or your cousins or
whatever richard dawkins talks about
this in the selfish gene the purpose of
our life the way we're driven by our
genes to reproduce our genes it's not
about john barnes or constantine kissing
on francis absolutely it's the genes
that you carry wanting to replicate
exactly so that's why you don't want
more than your son but i think what i'm
saying is it's very natural for us to
want more to to want as high a status as
possible especially for males and to
have as much resources why especially
for males because males have a much more
status driven instinct than than women
do is it's it's just the nature of it
that's how we have become
that's what we've become how we've been
what you think is just naturally in us
it's how we evolve you think so yeah i
do okay i mean look we've had a lot of
evolutionary biologists and
psychologists on the show do you believe
in race
i haven't that is something i haven't
thought don't know enough about the
evolutionary stuff i i feel pretty well
schooled on
i don't understand what you mean when
you say
when you say race isn't a thing yeah but
i'm open to hearing an argument on it
yeah well i mean if you read a lot of
geneticists they'll tell you what why
does the race because there are some
white northern europeans who are
genetically closer to black west
africans
than a black west african to a black
east african not the gene that makes
them black yeah but other genes in terms
of our genetic makeup right so why
aren't they the same race because the
gene that makes us black is the same as
a gene that makes someone have blue eyes
and brown eyes yeah so why aren't the
people who have blue eyes at different
races people have brown eyes yeah why
are they it's one of the different race
well genetics is sorry just on this very
point
genetics is a complicated one because we
judge race on phenotype yeah on how we
look
that's why people would say you're one
race and i'm another race yeah but a
blue eyes it's different to a brown eyes
they look differently so why is it just
the color of the skin it's a good point
it is a good point and that's why
genetic assistant biologists have always
said race does not exist as we know it
because race before that was always
cultural because you had people of of as
long as you buy into the political life
like if you go back to the greeks you
buy into the political ideology then you
can be the same racist well that's what
i've always said about this country
that's what i love about britain which
is the idea and in some ways america
hasn't obviously hasn't lived up to this
ideal in every way but the idea is if
you come to america
and you integrate and you become part of
that society you are an american doesn't
matter where you come from doesn't
matter what you are now that's the ideal
they haven't lived up to that admittedly
and the same with britain as a foreigner
who came here like you at the age of 13
or 12 or whatever it was i feel like we
can all be british as long as we stop
looking at each other
the country that espouses that narrative
more than anyone is france not britain
because britain says you can hold on to
your identity you don't have to be
british i i respond to identity i resist
yeah but that's what britain says i know
i know britain says that france doesn't
and i wish there was because there is no
official consensus of how many black
people in france because they're none
because they're all french or muslims
because they're all french so the
ideology after the french revolution was
that you're all friends but reality is
the same it's different whereas in
england we don't do that as much as you
would like that and you think that that
is not the case because here in england
we say hold on to your identity and in
many respects you know why
because you'll never be british you hold
on to your identity so think about that
when you think how how together it is in
america black america and i said why are
why why do you talk about black
americans or native americans because
the the idea of greatness is to be
american right yeah
europe they don't say european american
do they because they consider themselves
to be american and that is that is what
we all want to be so why there's a black
american who is obvious you're black so
therefore we know where your forefathers
would have come from so why can't you
just say i'm an american or a native
american in fact native americans are
the americans they are the americans the
european americans are european american
black americans are black americans so
in many respects from an american
perspective it's not even a question of
black or native it's about or black or
or any other color or any other race it
is being an american and if you look at
black americans their american-ness
comes out when they're with other black
people
because of course if all black people
are in a room and it's from africa and
jamaica and when you're and you're a
black american you want them to know
you're an american
because an american is superior to other
people so that is when you become
american but when you're in america you
become black american
it's a very interesting way of looking
at it it's it just seems to me that
we're having a very reductive
conversation about race because so race
is complex and it's nuanced so right so
the point i'm making is that no point
talking about whether race exists or not
because as far as we're concerned it
does so while this is a very nuanced and
complex way of thinking and this is the
right way of thinking if you really want
to deconstruct the whole idea that
racism doesn't exist but we've gone too
far to even tell black people that
you're not black or white people
whatever right so
the point the whole point about my book
and this whole discussion for me is yes
let's accept that race success as much
as it does let's accept it does however
what we have to fight against are the
characteristics labeled to certain races
which were lies and they're not real and
you you use that example in the book
with calling a black player powerful and
then using the example of a dharma trial
or someone like didio drugba and that is
a perfect way to describe them they're
powerful players now i understand
because people go you know because black
people have been called lazy and be
called just their strengths so you know
as if i
saw an to commentators talk and you can
see them go you know pushing back and
they go they recognize that they talk
about they said that's a very powerful
run by unintelligent as well
and they have to put it in and we've
heard it all the time and listen it's
just like
look we know what's going on so why do
we have to do that because i know i know
the historic perception of black people
slaves whatever you want to talk about
we have to change that perception and
changing the perception isn't elevating
black people out of that negative space
because some black men and in fact quite
a lot lots of black men are jet black
with big lips and a round head
so are we now trying to say that's not
what black people are like because when
we see that figure we go you know not
all black people are like that why are
they showing that but if they show up an
image of john bonds light skin thinner
lips no one will go not all black men
are like that some of them have got big
lips and black skin we won't do that
because we are ashamed of that image and
that's what we have to do as black
people get away from that image i mean
i've got in the book and it's in we call
it in jamaica right in the emancipation
part where i have penis park
there's a statue of the slaves who came
to jamaica now if you look at apollo
belvedere and they look at the greek
statues of of a thousand years ago and
it is about their beauty
and it is about their intelligence so
while they're sculptured and never mind
what they look like you can see that
this is a because they make them with
obviously very little you know or
sometimes they have none because that's
not what's important the importance of
their beauty their their their
intelligence that's what this is about
in penis park the big black slaves
they've made him with a
that big
which people are like why do we have to
then
show that you know okay we are i've got
bigger dicks than everybody else for our
masculinity
because this is how we have been
conditioned to think we have been
dehumanized to then be reduced to just
being seen as a physical specimen and
that's what we have to get away from
ourselves before white people can get
away from seeing
us in that way we have to get away from
seeing us that way ourselves so when we
see a caricature if it's a caricature
and a caricature is a black man with big
lips and a black face why is that racist
because some black men have black
bigness and black faces and i know the
history of slavery and colonism when you
know the black man was dehumanized to
look whatever but but we we ourselves
have to get away from that john do you
think
this is something that worries me quite
a lot and i think i don't know whether
you'd agree with me but i feel like you
you're talking about the same thing i
feel like
you know when i was growing up my
parents brought me up to treat everybody
the same way and my greatest hero when i
was a kid was michael jordan
like i i was a huge fan of his i played
basketball not very well but i did i
loved michael jordan he was an
inspirational man he was an
inspirational player he was he was
brilliant in every way
it never occurred to me that he was
quote unquote a different race it never
occurred to me
and i worry that the way we're having
these conversations now my children they
might look up and see lebron james or
whoever the current superstars in the
gyani center to coompa whoever it is
i don't think they'll be able to notice
santa cumpo thank you yeah because i
always try to say second name i just
wanted to make sure you said it right
yeah yeah i'm a big boss
but
i don't know that my children
will be able to have that pure
experience of admiring another man
without thinking that they've noticed
what you've said doesn't exist which is
his race yeah
do you worry about that
no what i worry about is when people
may convince themselves in terms of you
know not seeing kind of not seeing race
and and and they just looking and we're
having it now in football whereby what
we've actually said and i think the
european championship proved that
that when gareth southgate talks about
this new
diverse england football team and i
remember in 1984 playing in a game with
their five black players on the pitch
and since then we've had five and six
and seven black players playing for
england so why now all of a sudden it's
the new diverse england football team as
if black players hadn't played before
and before they missed those penalties
everything was okay and as soon as they
missed the penalties so what you're
actually saying is and the people you
admire obviously are successful
black black people
that's not what we have to do we don't
have to look at successful black people
and convince ourselves that you know
we're either not racially biased because
we love these successful black people
what about if they're not successful
what happens then because of course we
love sterling and rashford and everybody
before they miss the penalties as soon
as they're missing penalties you see
what society thinks of them a section of
society thinks of them and that's what
we have to change stop looking for
brilliant black people to say things are
changing because we're looking up to
these brilliant black people we have to
change the perception of the average
black person down below that's when we
really get rid of racial bias because
it's very easy margaret that's the first
female prime minister has things changed
for women
no
cressida dick now she's having a hard
time after the sarah problem because
she's a woman she can't change anything
within that system because just putting
elite people in power or loving elite
people michael jordan you have to look
at the average black person because when
they look at the average or the black
failure and they say you know black can
black people be good enough because they
failed at that how many white failures
have there been but no one thinks that
white people generally will fail because
the individual has failed but we do that
with blackness so when i see people who
love brilliant black people
but this is how we have to recondition
our mind yeah look at the average black
person walking down the street smoking a
split and he's got his jeans around his
ass his dreadlocks and say yes i see him
a sequel because you know when you talk
about even white people who say they
don't see some white people
have to stop saying white people someone
people like some black people who say
they don't see everyone up we see
everyone as equal yeah we see everyone
as an equal there's only two
possibilities half of how they see
people as equal because we all see
ourselves in a particular space in the
world
up there donald trump obviously some
[ __ ] them people wherever we see
ourselves and we see so we see black
people as equal when we say we see black
people as equal not a black person
black people
we see ourselves a particular space we
either
because we know where the perception of
black people are which is generally down
below white people we either bring them
up to our level to see them as equal if
some white people or we bring ourselves
down to their level to see them as equal
and which one do you think it normally
is
it normally is elevating them to a level
where you see them as equal so why
do you have to elevate them to see in
this vehicle where is your unconscious
possession of them to begin with so
they'll even talk about we see them as
equal it's really rising them up above
to where the general perception of the
john let me disagree with you since you
alluded to it to me saying i i was
inspired by michael jordan i didn't say
that i was my parents brought me up to
see everybody as equal my parents
brought me up to treat everybody as if
they're my equal there's a difference
i'm not claiming that i see a guy with
his pants down smoking a spliff as my
equal yeah whatever their skin color
yeah to me that's a different issue
entirely if someone is smoking a spliff
in the middle of the street and they've
got their pants around their ankles it
doesn't really matter to me what the
race is that's a different issue but my
point is
i was brought up to treat everybody
equally and now i feel like the
conversation has moved away from that
and we're having a different
conversation and what i was getting at
is do you think that's constructive
well
the narrative from a lot of black people
i picked black elite is that i don't
care how you see me okay how you treat
me now you've just said you've been
brought up to treat everybody as yeah
if you don't see everybody as equal
you're not going to treat them as equal
it's impossible for you to treat them as
equal if you don't see them as equal you
may be forced to in your job or in
situations but if you don't see them as
equal they're always going to be ways to
make you not
um treat them equally after a while
so if we turn it around and say
we care how we see people and as long as
we then see them as equal there'll be no
reason for us to treat them unequally so
the whole idea of which we've been doing
for years and years after the american
civil war um we had black senators black
people got the vote mainly because white
northern america has wanted to
disenfranchise southern america and
they've got more votes to disenfranchise
but then after 20 years they realize
they're gonna have to deal with these
white southerners and we have to be on
an equal level because we saw them as
equal so then the jim crow laws came in
and we've been trying to treat black
people as equal ever since rather than
seeing them as equal and that has never
worked it never works we have to change
our perception switch it around to
seeing people as equal so this whole
thing about let's treat people as equal
for example at football matches
you used to be able to go
now you can't do that anymore can you
you can't do that anymore but if a black
player came to take a throne and i
scratched my armpit you know what i'm
doing don't you
but you call the referee or the police
and i say to him i'm scratching my
armpit mr policeman is it illegal to
scratch your armpit let's make armpit
scratching illegal okay we'll boo
can we boo every time a black player
gets the ball yes we can we know what
you're doing you're not making a monkey
noise let's make booing illegal we'll
clap
there's always going to be a way around
so we have to stop thinking about
treating people as equal first
we have to see them as equal then
there'll be no laws necessary to treat
them as equal and how do you see people
as equal surely that is something how we
see people as equal is we have to say
why do we see them as unequal to begin
with and how we see them as equal to
begin with because the way we have been
conditioned to think about them and
that's what we have to deconstruct
because it's not natural to wake up and
think i'm better than a woman of course
if it's going to be a physical
confrontation fine but in terms of
managing a fortune 500 company or a
black person's ability to think or let's
go to war who would i rather go to war
with
a gay guy or a skinner with tattoos
because have we been conditioned to
think
so this is the and unfortunately the
solution is not to put black people into
positions of power necessarily because
that's what we say as black people
because we have to make decisions so
what will happen is that dr tony steel
will be put in a position of power to
talk about the the racial disparities
within the within the system and he's
come back and said there's no systemic
racism
like if a white man said that we'd go oh
no it's because white people but we
wanted a black man up there and he said
the same thing so what are we going to
do
we can't complain can we
well talking about tony we've had him on
the show twice we've had tony on the
show twice and did he talk about this
with him yeah yeah we talked about the
rest he said there's no systemic racism
no he didn't actually he he said that
the report didn't say there was no
systemic racism the report pointed out
areas where there needs more
investigation right now
so the report may not have said that
that was reported what he actually said
in the report is that they are incidents
of racism not systemic racism yeah and
what have i said incidents of racism in
football matches so that's not systemic
racism and football message where
someone throws a banana on the field
because that does not affect that
footballer's life generally it affects
him for 90 minutes if he feels
disenfranchised yeah
so by then saying there are incidents of
racism
who is he supporting
black footballers elite black actors
can't get oscars elite now systemic
racism who does that affect
black
people power so therefore if he was
they've got no control they've got
going to attack the system
of which he's a part of
maybe boone wouldn't be where he is well
hold on you're being unfair to tony so
i'm going to defend them all francis you
can defend him if you want right right
so
when he was talking about that he was
also talking about things that affected
black people and talked about in a very
honest way for instance a statistic that
i found shocking and horrifying
is the fact that a black man is 24 times
more likely to be murdered than a white
man and to me the fact that we're not
talking about that
is an example for me of racism because
what that is saying is oh they're not
worthy to be discussed then we're not
discussing this statistic no that's not
a footballer
racism well well
his argument is it's uh you talked about
culture before right it's partly culture
it's partly he would i'm sure would in
fact i remember him saying uh it was
partly to do with the legacy of people
who came here and were disenfranchised
when they did so there's a distrust of
police there's a distrust of the
authorities which contributes to a lack
of fathers in the home in particular
communities that's a big part of it and
the main point this is why i think you
tell you and tony would actually get on
he talked about the class issue yeah
there's a big class dimension to this of
course there is and that's his answer
but there still is systemic racism which
reports says there is not well i'd love
you to have that conversation you would
get on with tony i'm sure
did he say there's no systemic right now
he didn't so why was that in the report
because the well you know the media yeah
come on yeah there you go so i can only
go from what i see in the media yeah so
yeah so he would say there's systemic
racism so why do you need to come out
he would not say there is or isn't
systemic racism their conclusion was
they didn't find evidence of there being
systemic racism but they did find a lot
of areas where there was
disenfranchisement disenfranchisement
for individuals right not systemic but
but that's the problem this is the
biggest problem okay because once again
you you can what racism can improve
the banana coming on the field
the overt racist that's not what's
stopping people no they talked about
disparities in education disparities in
health so why hasn't anything been done
about that i mean they they have the
course yeah
no no no no no totally but the point i'm
making is that yeah but because you you
you can arrest um not white working
class football fans or do whatever stop
them going in the racism the sexism the
homophobia you can't prove why don't
women report lots of rapes and sexual
abuse because the system is designed to
protect men that's why women will tell
you that we're men we're gonna go oh no
no no no no aren't we because that's
what men do
so the system discriminates against
women when it comes to sexual abuse
the system discriminates again the
system discriminates against black
people
it does some black people black people
generally not the ones who can get
themselves out of it or the eliteback
people so that's the point i'm making
what that report says if you can point
the finger at inconsequential people
yeah the the sex issue shouts an abuse
or or the rapist or the man who kills a
woman but the system still discriminate
against them and that is why you cannot
change things from within you can't be
part of the system and change it and the
biggest example of that and it's in the
book the esl european super league
liverpool real madrid barcelona all of
these top clubs they are the most
powerful clubs in uefa
why do so why don't they change it
because they know we can't change things
for ourselves within that existing
system so we have to leave it that's how
the premier league started liverpool
arsenal
everton when they were a big club can
you believe that
liverpool arsenal everton hall danton
united yeah nancy and chelsea weren't
there they wanted more for themselves
and they knew they had to leave the
football league or the football he
controlled it so that's why you can't
change family systems so why do we
believe that three percent black people
three percent
that we can get a few of us into the
system and it'll change for everybody
else
we can't do it
we can't do it and but i do want to go
back to that point about and i want to
get your take on it because to me i
found that very upsetting i was a
teacher and i used to work down the road
in newham and i used to see you know
kids get getting involved in gangs there
was one boy who when he left my primary
school he came back to see me and we
were talking and i was saying how how
are you doing that's a wide working
class kids yeah yeah
yeah absolutely but that statistic is
that statistic john it's horrifying why
are we not having an honest conversation
about it because the conversation we're
having is about eastern european fans
that's the problem with racism right
and and people on twitter abusing
football players for missing penalties
yeah that's why we're not doing anything
about it and that's why i say if the
elite black people like footballers and
marketers understand what did marcus
rashford do to change that imagine if
more footballers were to talk about yes
it's bad in eastern europe whatever but
the most important thing we have to do
is change what's going on in the cities
because marcus fractured was an original
thing it was on a privilege so if you
imagine if more footballers with the
platform and the clown because he knows
that politicians be afraid to go against
footballers particularly when they're
doing one that's what we should do as
black players wait till they score a
hat-trick then come out and say
something because if you miss a penalty
you've got no clout then so that's what
they should do use their voice to talk
about people less fortunate in
themselves and we started a conversation
talking about me as a 17 year old and i
noticed the inequality not for me
because i lived in highgate and nathan
my dad was a diplomat and i've got
bananas on the field okay but i noticed
the fact that what black people were
going through back then and nobody spoke
for them and now we're having and nobody
could i couldn't because then people go
just get on with it you play in the race
whatever whereas now we have an
opportunity to really make a tangible
difference
let's the tangible difference isn't
banning you hungry from you from from
uefa the tangible difference is what
marcus rashford did for what's going on
in our inner cities and that's what we
have to do and you think more people
need to stand up and more people need to
speak about this but isn't it the
problem john where if you see people
getting cancelled if you see people you
know getting dragged over the coals for
using the word colored instead of
absolutely we're never going to be never
going to be anywhere now of course
that's a different subject in terms of
from a wide perspective being able to
have the honest conversation about how
we truly feel
even if we talk about the perception
that we have and the illusion we have
that our black players can really make a
difference
they're taking a knee for racial
discrimination i haven't heard
skye bt any black player having a
meaningful discussion as to why there
are very few black managers
once again you have to be careful who
you who you criticize it's okay to
criticize eastern europe why are there
no black managers and it's because of
the unconscious bias i had a
conversation with a female journalist
funnily enough
and she says why do they know black
managers i said the only two reasons
one because
black players who want to be managers
are mainly unconsciously
discriminated against
if a black man gets a job at any club
everyone at that club wanting to do well
every fan because you love your club you
love your club that's that's how
beautiful football is you want to do
well but when he he will be given less
time to fail than a white manager
because if he loses a few matches put it
this way if his arteta said same thing
about klopp for the first three years
and they talk us and it's not personal
to klopper or tetan
if a black man was in that job they'd
lose their job quicker because of the
perception we have of their work to
begin with so i'm not accusing any fans
of being racist and it's you know it's
unconscious bias so i said either
because there's an unconscious bias
towards your ability before you see them
perform and if they perform and they
don't win all the games and they will
lose a few games white managers are
going to get the sack 100 but they will
be given longer
or
they're not good enough because of the
color of their skin so when anyone asks
a question oh can black men make good
managers that is a racist question
because it presupposes that he can't be
a manager because of the color of his
skin is that a possibility
so she said no there's another another
possibility i said what is that he goes
well maybe they don't want to be
managers she's a female sports
journalist i said you could be right
just like women don't want to be sports
journalists do they
because that's what they say to women
and women say of course we do why you
why are you saying that so what is it so
why aren't we having this discussion
and i'll tell you because it's and i'll
tell you why it's so obvious is because
of the perception we have of black
people generally in terms of their
ability to think because no matter how
good you are as a footballer once you
finish playing football then you become
a black person and what do we feel about
your intellectual and moral capabilities
and that's what management is in terms
of your intellect so they're not many
black managers so another group are
discriminated against managers are white
english managers
not in the lower divisions and the and
the bottom 14 teams in the premier
league after liverpool men united
chelsea they all lose their job tomorrow
there's not one right english manager's
gonna get that job because the
perception is foreign managers are
better
and that's so when a foreign manager
gets a job and no one's ever heard of
him no one that's an eyelid give eddie
hell the job
and united give him three games to lose
and see what actually happens so we
understand that his perception of even
white and white is supposed to be
superior but because they're english and
it's a negative perception of english
managers if that's very obvious why is
it so hard to even believe that and we
know the history of of the perception of
black people that black managers aren't
being given jobs because of their color
now after all of that why aren't they
talking about that
black players one black player spoke
about it got ostracized danny rose so
why all these talk taking the knee talk
about eastern europeans why aren't we
having this conversation is this the
elephant in the room
30 black players
and the black managers once again these
only nuances around discrimination and
how we've been conditioned to think the
black managers are given jobs our
foreign black managers patrick vieira
nunes spiriter in the premier league at
the clubs because we have a perception
that oh they're foreign oh no they're
black but not the black english ones
they're more imp they speak three
languages they're from europe they're
more intelligent why because of the
perception we have of them eric cantona
trawlers and seagulls
philosophers
let paul merson say that and see what
working with his cockney accent
so that is funny
but john
let me ask you this because
you've been very honest about how you
feel about these things and i'll be
honest with you about how i think a lot
of white people feel about this as well
you talk about marcus rashford i would
argue that one of the reasons his
campaign has been so successful is that
he hasn't made a racial
and so it makes it a lot easier for
white people to go well i'll support
that because it's not racial
that's my point but some things are
racial yeah no you have to pick and
choose what's right
absolutely agreed but i guess what i'm
saying is
do you not think uh that
for issues where race may be a factor
but it's not necessarily the main factor
in issues which are much more to do with
people's socio-economic so like you you
know we're about to move out of the
studio but people won't know this but
outside there's a council estate right
and
i walk through this council estate if i
spend 10 minutes in that environment i
can feel the ambition draining
i've seen any new offices in mayfair
i wish but you know what i mean right
you're in you're trying to be completely
so so what i'm saying is do you not
think that it's much more effective on
issues that are about social economics
to bring everybody together and to say
this ain't about your skin color this is
about the fact that you're poor that you
don't have a dad in the house so you've
got terrible teachers right etc so this
is what's been happening because of
course if you want allies if you want
allies yeah and it has to be white
allies yeah you can't get allies by
claiming everything is racist and of
course the system is quite happy for you
to do that
because the system doesn't want to
change
so therefore when you then
put label everything as racial when
things are racial people go oh there
they go again and you go well hang on a
second this one is oh you've said that
before you cry wolves too often yeah and
i'll give you lots of examples so um
when
pierce morgan on gmb comes out and he
says and it's in the press that oh look
at it now they're talking about his
races because the white chess piece
moves first before the black one anybody
who would be our ally are going on there
they go again
and of course the system is quite happy
for that to happen when you have a
situation and of course you then have
white military black militants who are
quite happy to go along with that which
turns the majority of good people yeah
although they may have a shallow
understanding but there's still good
people against it i have a situation
whereby and it's in the book and
about a a professor in in uh ivy league
american school having a
class a debate on poor sounds in between
language paul sounds in between language
as we're talking now we go uh um uh
those those sounds that we make in
between language and in mandarin
it's nega
n-e-i-g-e sounds like we know what it
sounds like and my son who's a doctor he
has a
doctor colleague she's from china and
she's speaking to her parents and he
hears he hears her saying it she's
speaking manually every now and then she
goes
and then he goes what are you saying
it's a pause it's a poor sound right
so
so it sounds funny now this has probably
been going on for thousands here in
china because i spoke before we could
even speak over here but anyway so this
is the sound they make and in the class
about paul's sounds in between he says
in mandarin they have this sound five
black students get up and walk out and
he gets suspended because it sounds like
that so of course people are gonna go
here we go the same thing with liam
neeson the same thing with the fourth
official from romania who says ala negro
the black guy there's nothing wrong with
saying the black guy so the point is is
that when it's really serious but then
all of a sudden yeah you play all of
those cards and then waters it down and
people go there they go play the race
card again and that is why as i said i
get so much stick from the from a lot of
some black people who say you're saying
nothing is racist and some white people
say saying everything is racist but the
problem is is the examples that you've
just used they're just very superficial
it's saying a word that sounds like
another word but actually having a
discussion where you have to dig deep
and you have to share and you have to
think and it has nuance and there aren't
easy answers people don't want to do
that because it's difficult and it's
hard and it takes time and there's no
easy answers to it and the system is
quite happy for those conversations not
to be had because then we'll actually
end up pointing the finger at the real
problem right people be they black be
they women be they gay or
disenfranchised rather than just focus
on footballers and actors and rappers
and then talk about eastern european
communists and and white working-class
people
john i so hear you because i i we get
this and we criticize a lot of this
stuff on our show the the superficiality
the oh here's you know the black chess
piece or whatever to me that's just
[ __ ] and it's a waste of everybody's
time but at the same time there are
legitimate issues with with all these
different groups absolutely and i notice
what you're talking about which is when
they're brought up everybody not
everybody but some people just they just
switch off and they go oh oh well every
th it's the same thing as that
absolutely well actually no i mean if
black kids are stabbing each other to
death at a rate 24 times as white kids
yeah that that needs to be dealt with
and we need and it's not because they're
black it's to do with the situation and
foundation very much like in poverty
right now why why are there these
poverty written areas to begin with so
that kind of exactly yeah but but but
for people like we'll switch on we'll
come back will they switch off he'll
come back and he'll go yeah but you see
that's black and black kids it's a black
problem and i said well one's in glasgow
with all white kids no one said it was a
white problem yeah it's an inner city
problem yeah exactly but no one wants to
push that so so that that's something
that needs to be investigated while all
the superficial stuff just needs to not
be talked about so that we can focus on
the things that matter yeah what i'm
hearing from you is you feel
that you've used the term several times
as the system
what do you mean the media do you mean
the government who do you mean when you
talk about the system well i mean is it
the firm that megan talks about so if
you want to talk the people who make the
decisions and the policy makers whoever
they are because when you talk about
even black role models for example and
um
black footballers you know if you go to
harvard princeton yale
oxford cambridge harrow school i don't
think that and these other people are
going to run rule the world
i don't think they're they're um
their role models are harry kane and
paul gascoigne for some reason probably
not i don't think whereas we're telling
our black is that your mother has to be
john ponton and mike tyson the boxers
and the sportsmen and stuff like that so
i'm just talking about the people who
rule the world and we you know i don't
know who they are but we're not winning
yeah exactly the illuminati there you go
yeah the rothschilds
and not the ones not the ones from from
iraq okay you've got shoes in iraq not
those ones
blue eyed jews
john it's been a pleasure it's been an
absolute pleasure thank you so much for
coming on the show
we're going to do some questions for our
locals which is just our supporters uh
before we do that um if people want to
find you online and everything else
where's the best they should buy the
book and they should buy the book number
one
i'm i'm i can just about send a text so
i don't know how they're going to find
me online to go to a phone box for 50p
because this social media thing i can
just about do twits and i'm messing up
on twitter because i'm pressing the
wrong button anyway so when you talk
about
instagram facebook i have not got a clue
so unfortunately you know i support the
book you can find the book somewhere but
if you want to find me i live on the
world come and have a cup of tea okay
fantastic and the last question we
always finish with is what's the one
thing we're not talking about but we
really should be just what we've been
talking about today
in the way we've been talking about it
fantastic john thank you so much for
coming on the show it's been a pleasure
guys if you've enjoyed this episode our
episodes always go out wednesday sunday
7 p.m uk time 2 p.m eastern standard we
also have raw shows as well the exact
same time and if you like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon
[Music]
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below